This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. This is the story of an ad campaign produced for the 1992 Olympic Games in Barcelona. Perennial runner-up in the sports shoe category, Reebok, was trying to make its mark and take down Nike. They chose two athletes, they plucked them out of obscurity, gave them re-boxed to wear, and turned them into household names, spending $25 million in the process. That was more than re-boxed entire marketing budget the previous year. This ad campaign is pretty much remembered as a disaster for re-bock, but it created from nothing, an epic drama that pitted two world-class decathletes against each
这里是《99%隐形》（99% Invisible）。我是罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）。这是关于1992年巴塞罗那奥运会期间制作的一则广告活动的故事。作为运动鞋领域的“千年老二”，锐步（Reebok）试图打响名号并击败耐克（Nike）。他们挑选了两名运动员，将他们从默默无闻中发掘出来，给他们穿上锐步鞋，并将他们打造成家喻户晓的明星，为此投入了2500万美元。这比锐步前一年的整个营销预算还要多。这则广告活动在锐步的历史上几乎被视为一场灾难，但它凭空创造了一场史诗般的戏剧，让两位世界级的十项全能运动员相互对抗，
other, and it resulted in so many strange twists and turns. All because someone thought it was a clever way to sell shoes. I love this story. This is the first episode of 30 for 30 podcasts, which are original audio documentaries from ESPN. These are stories about sports, but they're the sports stories that I like that delve into their impact on culture, politics, and more. Here's host Jody Avrigan to guide you through the trials of Dan and Dave.
并引发了许多离奇的转折。这一切仅仅是因为有人认为这是一种推销鞋子的聪明方法。我喜欢这个故事。这是ESPN原创音频纪录片系列《30 for 30》播客的第一集。这些故事关于体育，但我喜欢这些深入探讨它们对文化、政治等方面影响的体育故事。下面由主持人乔迪·阿夫里根（Jody Avrigan）带你了解丹（Dan）和戴夫（Dave）的考验。
Five at the Metradome in the Twin Cities of Minneapolis and St. Paul, Super Bowl number 26. So I had a party at my apartment, and I got the six foot subway sub. That was the centerpiece, was the six foot sub. And I, you know, because I had a little money, and it's like, man, I bought all the booze, all the beer. And I quite a few people come over, and it got a little wild.
明尼阿波利斯和圣保罗双子城的Metrodome体育场，第26届超级碗。我在公寓里办了个派对，买了一个六英尺长的赛百味三明治。那是重头戏，就是那个六英尺长的三明治。而且，你知道，因为我当时有点钱，我就买了所有的酒，所有的啤酒。来了不少人，场面变得有点疯狂。
Super Bowl 26, January 26, 1992. Almost 80 million people watching on television. Many of them from parties like the one at D'Anneau Bryant's house. Everybody was drinking beer, and then we got into the heart alcohol, and it was really fun. Dan is watching from Moscow, Idaho. Dave Johnson is watching from Los Angeles, California. I probably had 30 or 40 people at my house
第26届超级碗，1992年1月26日。电视机前有近8000万人观看。其中许多人像丹诺·布莱恩（D'Anneau Bryant）家里的派对一样。每个人都在喝啤酒，后来我们开始喝烈酒，真的很有趣。丹在爱达荷州的莫斯科市观看。戴夫·约翰逊（Dave Johnson）在加利福尼亚州的洛杉矶观看。我家里大概有30到40个人，
with multiple TVs set up. And everybody's there, and I kind of kept it a little bit of a secret. I just let them know why T.C. what's going to be on here. And so the first commercial comes on, and it's super short. It's in the third quarter, just before a Pepsi ad featuring Cindy Crawford. The first Dan and Dave commercial runs, featuring old photographs and grainy videos of two toddlers, Daniel Bryan and Dave Johnson.
摆了好几台电视。每个人都在那儿，我把这事儿当成了一个小秘密。我只是让他们知道电视上会播什么。然后第一个广告出现了，非常短。它在第三节，就在百事可乐那则由辛迪·克劳馥（Cindy Crawford）主演的广告之前。第一则丹和戴夫的广告播出了，展示了两个蹒跚学步的孩子——丹尼尔·布莱恩（Daniel O'Brien）和戴夫·约翰逊——的老照片和颗粒感十足的视频。
Dan can run 100 meters in 10.3 seconds. Dave can I jump six feet, 10 and three quarter inches. This summer, they'll battle it out in Barcelona for the title of world's greatest athlete. The voiceover expounds on the man's athletic feats, but the visuals are just the photos of the two toddlers. Me and a bathtub, Dave on a bike, there was just little kids. And that's it. And everybody kind of looks around like, that's it. What the heck was that? Then, later in the same commercial break, another short ad runs.
丹可以在10.3秒内跑完100米。戴夫可以跳出6英尺10.75英寸的高度。今年夏天，他们将在巴塞罗那争夺“世界最伟大运动员”的头衔。旁白讲述着这些人的运动壮举，但画面只是那两个蹒跚学步孩子的照片。我在浴缸里，戴夫在骑自行车，那只是小孩子。就这样。每个人都环顾四周，心想：就这？那到底是什么鬼？然后，在同一个广告时段稍后，又播出了另一则短广告。
Dan can throw a 16-pound shot put 53 feet 3 inches. Dave can actually shoot. More pictures and home videos. Only in this one, the kids are a little older, maybe 5 or 6. The second ad ends the same way as the first, a quick Reebok logo and a promise. This summer they'll battle it out in Barcelona for the title of World's greatest athlete. I didn't know what to expect, they didn't show us the commercials before we saw them at the Super Bowl. Reebok ran two more
丹可以把16磅重的铅球扔出53英尺3英寸。戴夫其实可以投篮。又是更多的照片和家庭录像。只是在这一则里，孩子们大了一点，大概5或6岁。第二则广告的结尾和第一则一样，一个快速闪过的锐步标志和一个承诺。今年夏天，他们将在巴塞罗那争夺“世界最伟大运动员”的头衔。我不知道该期待什么，他们在超级碗播出前并没有给我们看这些广告。锐步又播出了两则
commercials, making four in total, all during the third quarter, and all of them just 15 seconds long. Dan won the Decathlon at the World Track and Field Championships. Dave won the Decathlon at the Goodwill Games. This summer they'll battle it out in Barcelona for the title of World's greatest athlete. I remember people really being confused at first,
广告，总共四则，全部在第三节播出，每则只有15秒长。丹赢得了世界田径锦标赛的十项全能冠军。戴夫赢得了友好运动会的十项全能冠军。今年夏天，他们将在巴塞罗那争夺“世界最伟大运动员”的头衔。我记得人们起初真的很困惑，
and then eventually they were going, man, that is genius. They were talking about how amazing that Reebok thought of doing small little commercials all the way to where there's a culmination of what they're really we're talking about, and that's these two athletes that are going to go to the Olympics this year, and it's going to be Zelda and Marsalona. By the way the game it's pretty lame with Washington beating Buffalo 3724
然后最终他们开始说，天哪，这真是天才之作。他们谈论着锐步想到制作这些小广告是多么了不起，一直到最后揭示了他们真正想表达的内容，那就是这两位今年要去参加奥运会的运动员，而且地点是在巴塞罗那。顺便说一句，比赛本身挺无聊的，华盛顿以37比24击败了布法罗，
but the ads have made their impact. When the Super Bowl was over and the party was over and everybody got out of there and it was a little bit shocking really. It's like, wow, we're here to celebrate commercials that I was in. I remember sitting with a group of people that I had there and they were all going to go in, I can't believe I'm sitting there and that we're here with Dave. And I never really thought of myself that way that somebody would think it's cool to be with Dave. And I never really thought of myself that way, that somebody would think it's cool to be with Dave.
但这些广告产生了影响。当超级碗结束，派对结束，大家都离开后，真的有点令人震惊。就像是，哇，我们在这里庆祝我参与的广告。我记得当时和一群人坐在一起，他们都说，我不敢相信我正坐在这里，我们正和戴夫在一起。我从来没想过自己会是那样的人，会有人觉得和戴夫在一起很酷。我从来没想过自己会是那样的人，会有人觉得和戴夫在一起很酷。
That was the first time I really sat there who was going on. You know, people are going to know who I am now. And I remember almost being scared, you know, what do you do with that? Get your body. In 92, Reebok was known primarily as a shoe that your mom wore to take a robious class is in. And they were desperate to increase their athletic
那是我第一次真正坐下来思考发生了什么。你知道，人们现在会知道我是谁了。我记得当时几乎感到害怕，你知道，你该怎么处理这些？在92年，锐步主要被认为是你妈妈穿去上健美操课的鞋子。他们迫切地想要提升自己的运动
credibility. In 1992, Rick Siddig worked for Shiet Day. The ad agency hired to put together Reebok's latest campaign. The task agency hired to put together Rebox latest campaign. Rebox! The task was pretty daunting. We've got two guys no one's ever heard of in an event no one really cares about. All of the best-known athletes were Nike athletes. The Michael Jordan's of the world,
信誉。1992年，里克·西迪格（Rick Siddig）为谢伊·戴（Chiat/Day）工作。这家广告代理公司被聘请来策划锐步最新的广告活动。任务非常艰巨。我们有两个没人听说过的人，参加一项没人真正关心的赛事。所有最知名的运动员都是耐克旗下的。像迈克尔·乔丹（Michael Jordan）那样的人，
the most famous professional athletes in the world. If we wanted to stand out, we needed to do something else. The basic idea was, in sport circles, the winner of the Decathlon is the world's greatest athlete. And so, it wasn't hard for Reebok to get excited about a campaign that said, who's the world's greatest athlete? This Reebok athlete you've never heard of? Or this other re-bock athlete you've never heard of?
世界上最著名的职业运动员。如果我们想脱颖而出，我们需要做点别的。基本理念是，在体育圈里，十项全能的冠军就是“世界最伟大运动员”。所以，锐步很容易对一个打出“谁是世界最伟大运动员？”口号的活动感到兴奋。是这个你从未听说过的锐步运动员？还是那个你从未听说过的锐步运动员？
The de-cathlon by nature is, in my opinion, the toughest of all the track and field of bins. The de-cathlon is so tough because it combines so much. Its 10 events contested over the course of two days each one adding to the competitors overall point total. Day 1 is a 100 meter dash, long jump, shot put, high jump and the 400 meter run. Day 2 is a 110 meter hurdles, discus, pull-fong, javelin, and last the 1,500 meter run. Then it attracts some really interesting individuals. We don't say that athletes find the de-Cathlon.
在我看来，十项全能本质上是所有田径项目中难度最大的。十项全能之所以艰难，是因为它结合了太多东西。它在两天内进行10个项目的角逐，每一项都计入选手的总分。第一天是100米短跑、跳远、铅球、跳高和400米跑。第二天是110米栏、铁饼、撑杆跳、标枪，最后是1500米跑。它吸引了一些非常有趣的人。我们不说运动员找到了十项全能，
We say that the de-Cathlon will find those athletes. That's what happened to me. I think that's what happened to Dave. Born in 1963, Dave Johnson grew up in Montana and Oregon. By his own admission, he was hardly the model young man. I was one of those kids that was in a lot of trouble growing up. I was actually throwing snowballs at cars and I think I did definitely learn how to throw so well because I was able to stand farther back than anybody else and throw that apple or throw that snowball, throw that rock. I remember the first time a coach told me what the de-Cathalon was. He said, you should
我们说十项全能会找到那些运动员。我就是这样，我想戴夫也是这样。戴夫·约翰逊出生于1963年，在蒙大拿州和俄勒冈州长大。据他自己承认，他绝不是模范少年。我小时候是个惹了很多麻烦的孩子。我当时其实在向汽车扔雪球，我想我之所以学会了扔得那么准，是因为我能比别人站得更远，然后扔出那个苹果、那个雪球或那块石头。我记得第一次有教练告诉我什么是十项全能时。他说，你应该
do the de-Cathalon. I thought he said marathon. I coached no, I'm the herdler. I don't run distance. He was, no, no, the de-Cathalon. He said, you know, Bruce Jenner. And I go, well, Bruce Jenner, that's a guy on chips. I remember watching television. There's a genre was on a show called Chips at the time. He was doing a cameo with them. And so I just knew him as a Hollywood TV guy. And he said, no, he was an Olympic medalist. Dave Johnson was hooked.
去练十项全能。我以为他说的是马拉松。我说，不，我是跨栏运动员。我不跑长距离。他说，不，不，是十项全能。他说，你知道布鲁斯·詹纳（Bruce Jenner）吗？我说，哦，布鲁斯·詹纳，那是演《警网急先锋》（CHiPs）的那个家伙。我记得看电视，詹纳当时在演一部叫《警网急先锋》的剧。他在里面客串。所以我只知道他是好莱坞电视明星。他说，不，他是奥运奖牌得主。戴夫·约翰逊被吸引住了。
Daniel Bryan also grew up in Oregon, just a few hours south of Dave near the small town of Klamath Falls. And he also had his ups and downs before finding his sport. Well growing up in Southern Oregon, to me, always felt like I was out of place. You know, we had six adopted kids in the family. I have a sister who's biracial like myself, a little brother who's Hispanic. I have a Native American sister and then two Korean sisters. Well, when you're the only kid of color or kids of color in your entire town, which the O'Brien family was,
丹尼尔·布莱恩也成长于俄勒冈州，就在戴夫南边几小时车程的克拉马斯福尔斯小镇附近。在找到自己的运动项目之前，他也经历过起起落落。嗯，在俄勒冈州南部长大，对我来说，总感觉自己格格不入。你知道，我们家里有六个领养的孩子。我有一个和我一样是混血儿的姐姐，一个西班牙裔的弟弟。我有一个美洲原住民姐姐，还有两个韩国姐姐。嗯，当你所在的整个城镇里只有你一个有色人种孩子，或者说只有你们几个有色人种孩子时——奥布莱恩一家就是这样——
it's interesting because all you wanna do when you're young is fit in. Blend in, go along, get along. And there we are, looking like the rainbow coalition. Every time we get out of the car and go to church, the movies, it's a very weird feeling when everybody's watching you. And I can just remember thinking,
这很有趣，因为当你年轻时，你只想融入其中。随大流，相处融洽。而我们看起来就像个“彩虹联盟”。每次我们下车去教堂、看电影，当每个人都盯着你看时，那是一种非常奇怪的感觉。我记得我当时心想，
you know, why are people staring at me? Why are people staring at us? This is just our regular family. And it wasn't until I got into sports that I really felt like I belonged. I always thought that sports was the equalizer for me. Didn't matter what you looked like or where you came from.
你知道，为什么人们盯着我看？为什么人们盯着我们看？这只是我们普通的家庭。直到我开始参加体育运动，我才真正感到自己属于那里。我一直认为体育对我来说是平衡器。无论你长什么样，无论你来自哪里，都不重要。
If you were good at sports, you were good. And Dan was good. He became a star athlete in high school, landed a scholarship at the University of Idaho, and there started to compete in the Decathlon. And in his senior year, 1988, he first crossed paths with Dave Johnson, a few years older, and already well established on the scene. You know, Dave was the best American up until that point, but Dan's star was rising quickly and others in the tight knit track community were starting to notice. I'm Jackie Jonah Cursey, the world's greatest female athlete. Jackie Jonah Cursey can say that even now thanks to her six Olympic medals and the
如果你擅长体育，你就是优秀的。而丹很优秀。他在高中时成为明星运动员，获得了爱达荷大学的奖学金，并从那里开始参加十项全能比赛。在他大四那年，即1988年，他第一次与戴夫·约翰逊相遇，戴夫比他大几岁，在圈内已经很有名气了。你知道，戴夫在那之前是美国最优秀的选手，但丹的明星光芒正在迅速升起，紧密的田径圈里的其他人也开始注意到这一点。我是杰基·乔伊娜-克西（Jackie Joyner-Kersee），世界最伟大的女子运动员。杰基·乔伊娜-克西即使在今天也能这么说，多亏了她的六枚奥运奖牌和
Heptathlon World Record, she said, in 1988, that still stands today. When you see this young talent, it's just a matter of time. They're going to have this big breakthrough. Well, it's interesting. Jackie Joiner Cursey made the comment that I could be the next Bruce Jitter. And that was what I was striving to do, you know, most of my career. He was the hero that we all needed in 1976
七项全能世界纪录，她在1988年创下的纪录至今仍未被打破。当你看到这种年轻的天才时，这只是时间问题。他们会迎来巨大的突破。嗯，很有趣。杰基·乔伊娜-克西曾评论说我可能会成为下一个布鲁斯·詹纳。那也是我职业生涯大部分时间里努力追求的目标。他是我们在1976年所需要的英雄，
and he was the golden boy. And Dan was that very explosive athlete. I mean, he was just this young kid, very raw, very talkative. And he had a personality that could pull people to him. We're a perfect combination. I think he and I were a great duo that was meant to be where we were going to push each other to the levels that we ended up going to. And by the time the 1992 Barcelona Olympics had come into view, Dan and Dave had pushed each other to the top of the global stage. Dan won the decathlon at the World Track and Field Championships. Dave won the decathlon at the World Tracking Field Championships.
他是那个时代的金童。而丹是一个非常有爆发力的运动员。我的意思是，他只是个年轻的孩子，非常青涩，非常健谈。他有一种能吸引人的个性。我们是完美的组合。我认为我和他是天作之合，我们注定要将彼此推向我们最终达到的高度。当1992年巴塞罗那奥运会临近时，丹和戴夫已经将彼此推向了全球舞台的顶端。丹赢得了世界田径锦标赛的十项全能冠军。戴夫赢得了
Dave won the decathlon at the G. You know, usually the multivance or dominated by the Europeans. And finally, in America, it's the breakthrough. And all of a sudden, it's like, wow, you're still at seeing this young talent put it all together. And among the observers who took notice were the executives at Reebok. Your mom's apparel company was on the hunt for athletes to get into business with. Dan and Dave, two dominant competitors,
友好运动会的十项全能冠军。你知道，通常多项全能项目都是由欧洲人主导的。而终于，在美国，出现了突破。突然之间，就像是，哇，你还在看着这些年轻天才把一切整合在一起。在注意到这一点的观察者中，就有锐步的高管。你妈妈的服装公司正在寻找运动员进行合作。丹和戴夫，两位极具统治力的竞争者，
but unknown personalities were the perfect fit. Here are two athletes putting our sport, you know, in the line light, to have that commercial showing doing the Super Bowl was wow. And we kind of looked at each other like wow, you know. These two young little decafetes were getting a lot of attention and it's about time and track and field athletes got that. The decaf one? Really? Us? This is unheard of. I can't believe they're asking us to do this. This is what Jordan does.
但个性不为人知，是完美的契合。这是两位运动员让我们的运动项目进入聚光灯下，在超级碗期间播放那则广告真是太棒了。我们看着对方，就像是，哇，你知道。这两个年轻的小十项全能选手得到了很多关注，田径运动员得到这些关注是时候了。十项全能？真的吗？我们？这闻所未闻。我不敢相信他们让我们做这个。这是乔丹做的事。
Michael Jordan and Bo Jackson, all the best basketball football guys do. With Dan and Dave, Reebok was looking to promote their new cross-trainer to the masses. A shoe designed for use across multiple sports and workouts. The greatest athlete at the time was Bo Jackson. And he played two sports. Bo knew everything Nike's campaign went. But the truth was, Dan and Dave were more equipped to back up that claim.
迈克尔·乔丹和博·杰克逊（Bo Jackson），所有最棒的篮球和橄榄球运动员都在做。通过丹和戴夫，锐步希望向大众推广他们的新款交叉训练鞋。这是一款专为多种运动和锻炼而设计的鞋子。当时最伟大的运动员是博·杰克逊。他参加两项运动。博知道一切，耐克的广告活动就是这么走的。但事实是，丹和戴夫更有资格支持这一主张。
So when I look at Bo Jackson, he's a great baseball player, he's a great football player, but you know what? I thought I was the girl's greatest athlete because I could do 10 of it. And that thought played right into the case, Reebok was trying to make, as they rolled out more and more ads after the Super Bowl. Hi, World's Greatest Athlete here to talk to you about Reebok's new running
所以当我看着博·杰克逊时，他是一位伟大的棒球运动员，他是一位伟大的橄榄球运动员，但你知道吗？我认为我是世界最伟大的运动员，因为我能做10个项目。那个想法正好契合了锐步在超级碗之后推出越来越多广告时试图证明的观点。嗨，世界最伟大运动员在此，和你谈谈锐步的新款跑步
cross trainer. Hi, World's Greatest Athlete here to talk to you. Hey, excuse me, Reebok asked me to talk about the new running cross trainer. Oh, no, this is my commercial. Mine. Mine. Mine. The boldness of Reebok to come out with two people was really incredible. My name is Steve Miller and at the time of Dan and Dave, I was the head of a US sports marketing for Nike and we became very aware of the fact that Reebok was on to something very special. What you're looking for as a consumer is somebody who does something that you can't do, or something you aspire to do, or somebody who inspires you.
交叉训练鞋。嗨，世界最伟大运动员在此，和你谈谈。嘿，打扰一下，锐步让我谈谈新款跑步交叉训练鞋。哦，不，这是我的广告。我的。我的。我的。锐步敢于推出两个人的大胆做法真的很不可思议。我叫史蒂夫·米勒（Steve Miller），在丹和戴夫那个时期，我是耐克美国体育营销的负责人，我们非常清楚锐步正在做一些非常特别的事情。作为消费者，你寻找的是那些能做你做不到的事情的人，或者你渴望做的事情，或者能激励你的人。
And Dan and Dave caught the eye and the ear of consumers throughout the country and globally as well. Dave, run, run, run, run, run, run. Each time that Reebok ran the commercial and revised it and upgraded Run, run, run, run. Each time that Reebok ran the commercial and revised it and upgraded it, you became more affectionate towards the two athletes. And so people picked their favorites. Who is the world's greatest athlete?
丹和戴夫吸引了全国乃至全球消费者的目光和耳朵。戴夫，跑，跑，跑，跑，跑，跑。每次锐步播出这则广告并进行修改和升级时，你对这两位运动员的感情就越深。所以人们选择了他们最喜欢的。谁是世界最伟大运动员？
Dan or Dave? Dan's mom? Dan. Dave's mom? Dan's dentist. Dan. Dave's mailman? Dan's girlfriend? Dan. Dave's dentist. Damn. Dave's mailman.
丹还是戴夫？丹的妈妈？丹。戴夫的妈妈？丹的牙医？丹。戴夫的邮递员？丹的女朋友？丹。戴夫的牙医？丹。戴夫的邮递员？
Dave. Dan's girlfriend. Dan. Dave's wife. Dan's ex-girlfriend. Definitely. Dave. To be settled in Barcelona.
戴夫。丹的女朋友？丹。戴夫的妻子？丹的前女友？绝对是戴夫。将在巴塞罗那解决。
Reebok had a hit on their hands. I remember being in meetings and Reebok was just talking, we're going to compete with Nike. We're finally getting there. Reebok had filmed dozens of commercials to air during the spring. And while Dan and Dave had already known each other as rivals, the filming brought them closer together as friends. We were competing against each other to be better actors, but we were both not very good. And I think we both kind of knew that.
锐步手里握着一张王牌。我记得在会议上，锐步一直在说，我们要和耐克竞争。我们终于要成功了。锐步拍摄了数十则广告在春季播出。虽然丹和戴夫作为竞争对手早已认识，但拍摄过程让他们作为朋友更加亲近。我们为了成为更好的演员而相互竞争，但我们俩都不太擅长。我想我们俩都知道这一点。
And there was plenty of downtime to bond on the set. I couldn't believe for a 30-second commercial. It's setting up cameras and all kinds of stuff. It would take two days of 12-hour day shooting. You just sit around to shoot 30 seconds. Finally, they call for you, and you do an hour's worth of work. And Dave and I looked at each other a couple times and I was just, we said, I can't believe we're waste of time.
在片场有很多休息时间来建立感情。我无法相信，为了一个30秒的广告，要架设摄像机和各种东西。拍摄30秒需要两天，每天12小时。你只是坐在那儿等着拍30秒。最后，他们叫到你，你做了一个小时的工作。戴夫和我互看了几次，我只是，我们说，我不敢相信我们在浪费时间。
This is Dan Where's Reebok. By late February, Dan and Dave were on talk shows. Dan and Dave were giving joint press conferences. Dan and Dave were being profiled on local morning TV. Dave and I got to shoot a commercial with Simbad, the comedian. He was the most incredible guy because he was so chill off camera, but then when the lights are on, he went crazy.
这是丹，穿着锐步。到二月底，丹和戴夫上了脱口秀节目。丹和戴夫举行了联合新闻发布会。丹和戴夫在当地早间电视节目中被报道。戴夫和我拍了一则和喜剧演员辛巴德（Sinbad）合作的广告。他是最不可思议的人，因为他在镜头外非常随和，但当灯光亮起时，他就疯了。
Hey everybody, I'm Simbad. I'm here with Dan and Dave, and we're playing basketball today. And I didn't get the end of the day, my stomach hurt because I was laughing so hard. And Simbad was maybe the worst athlete I had ever seen. Here I was one of the top five sports celebrity figures in the U.S. Everybody knew who Dan and Dave was.
嘿大家，我是辛巴德。我和丹与戴夫在一起，我们今天在打篮球。我一天下来肚子都笑痛了。而辛巴德可能是我见过最差劲的运动员。当时我可是美国前五大体育名人之一。每个人都知道丹和戴夫是谁。
I remember Dan and I were just going, what do we do with this? Well, an athlete's life is pretty simple. You get up, you train, you eat, you go to bed, and you just repeat that cycle each and every day. When the day of the day of the campaign was going on, my life got complicated. I couldn't go anywhere. I mean, there was nothing. I couldn't go to that and outhouse and come out and there was a camera there to see if I washed my hands, I guess. And that's what I wasn't prepared for is to understand that you know what?
我记得丹和我只是在想，我们该怎么处理这个？嗯，运动员的生活很简单。你起床，训练，吃饭，睡觉，每天重复这个循环。当广告活动进行时，我的生活变得复杂了。我哪儿也去不了。我的意思是，什么都没有。我甚至不能去上个厕所出来，都有摄像机在那儿看着，我想是为了看我有没有洗手。我没准备好面对的是，你知道吗？
I just wasn't another face in the crowd. It got to a point where I told my managers we can't do this anymore. We just stopped appearances. We've got to get this thing going. I mean I've got like four months up until the trials. The trials. The trials. The first Dan and Dave ads aired at the Super Bowl in January of 1992. The Olympics were in Barcelona in July. To be settled in Barcelona.
我不再只是人群中的一张脸了。到了一个地步，我告诉我的经纪人，我们不能再这样了。我们停止了露面。我们必须把这件事搞定。我的意思是，距离选拔赛还有四个月。选拔赛。选拔赛。第一则丹和戴夫的广告于1992年1月在超级碗播出。奥运会于7月在巴塞罗那举行。将在巴塞罗那解决。
When Reebok approached Dave and I, the first thing both of us said was, you know neither one of us are on this team yet. We still have to go through the Olympic trials. Hello everyone and welcome to New Orleans at the US Olympic Track and Field Trials. The day already dawned. In 1992, the United States Olympic Track and Field Trials
当锐步找到戴夫和我时，我们俩说的第一件事就是，你知道我们俩都还没进这个队呢。我们还得通过奥运选拔赛。大家好，欢迎来到新奥尔良参加美国奥运田径选拔赛。这一天已经到来。1992年，美国奥运田径选拔赛
were held at Tad Gormley Stadium in New Orleans the last week of June. I arrived in New Orleans and I think the first thing that I noticed as soon as I got off the plane was it was hot. The heat was blistering. Up or 90s with 99% humidity or something like that. Whoo! Like nothing I'd ever experienced before. Everywhere you went, day and day, day and day, day and day, all eyes are on, who is gonna represent the United States and who we're going and when the go melt.
在6月的最后一周于新奥尔良的塔德·戈姆利体育场（Tad Gormley Stadium）举行。我到达新奥尔良，我想我下飞机后注意到的第一件事就是天气很热。热浪灼人。气温在90多华氏度，湿度有99%左右。呜！像我从未经历过的一样。无论你走到哪里，丹和戴夫，丹和戴夫，丹和戴夫，所有的目光都盯着，谁将代表美国，谁要去，谁会融化。
You have the pressure a little bit for me with Reebok and the money they'd spend, I better make this Olympic team was in my mind because everybody's wanting to know who's better. We've got to see who wins and borrows alone. That's the commercial. Meanwhile, the trials were Reebok's last big marketing events before Barcelona and the company took full advantage. I noticed everybody was wearing these white t-shirts. And hats that either had dand or dave on them. They either had a red dand and blue daves.
因为锐步和他们投入的资金，我确实感到了一点压力，我必须进入奥运代表队，这是我的想法，因为每个人都想知道谁更强。我们必须看看谁在巴塞罗那获胜。这就是广告。与此同时，选拔赛是锐步在巴塞罗那之前最后的大型营销活动，公司充分利用了这一点。我注意到每个人都穿着这些白色T恤。还有帽子，上面写着“丹”或“戴夫”。要么是红色的“丹”，要么是蓝色的“戴夫”。
And when you get into the stadium, everybody's wearing the t-shirts. And it was almost like somebody dropped them from a helicopter to all the people in the stands, at least half the people in the stands were wearing these white t-shirts. The top three finishers in the New Orleans de Cathlon would qualify for the Olympics. And the first day of events a Saturday went according to script, with Dan and Dave both racking up tons of points. Dave as usual was solid, while Dan, the reigning world champion, shot into first place.
当你进入体育场时，每个人都穿着这些T恤。简直就像有人从直升机上把它们扔给看台上的所有人，至少有一半看台的人穿着这些白色T恤。在新奥尔良十项全能中排名前三的选手将获得奥运会资格。第一天的比赛在周六按剧本进行，丹和戴夫都拿到了大量分数。戴夫一如既往地稳健，而现任世界冠军丹则冲到了第一名。
Somebody was telling me that I was ahead of world record pace, so that made me feel pretty good. Dan was on fire. If there were any concerns for either of them, it was a lingering foot injury for Dave, but he was the best second day to Kathleen of all time and the headlines leading into Sunday were all about whether or not he could catch up to his archival. They've dominated the airwaves. Now their battle really begins. Daniel Bryan and Dave Johnson, who will win the decafon? Over the first two events of the second day, hurdles and discus, Dave started to close the gap. And then...
有人告诉我，我领先于世界纪录的节奏，这让我感觉相当不错。丹状态火热。如果说他们俩有什么担忧的话，那就是戴夫挥之不去的脚伤，但他是有史以来最强的第二天十项全能选手，周日之前的头条新闻都在讨论他是否能追上他的宿敌。他们统治了广播。现在他们的战斗真正开始了。丹尼尔·布莱恩和戴夫·约翰逊，谁会赢得十项全能？在第二天的前两个项目——跨栏和铁饼之后，戴夫开始缩小差距。然后……
Sure enough, we got to the pole vault. The pole vault. The most stressful time, I think, de-cathlete or the coaches is the start of the povalt de-cathlete. Any coach will tell you that's where they're the most worried. In the povalt, competitors aim to clear increasing heights one by one. The higher the bar, the more points received. Each falter gets three attempts on a given height, and each can choose whatever height they'd like to start at.
果然，我们到了撑杆跳。撑杆跳。我认为对十项全能选手或教练来说，最紧张的时刻就是撑杆跳的开始。任何教练都会告诉你，那是他们最担心的地方。在撑杆跳中，选手们的目标是逐一越过不断升高的高度。横杆越高，得分越多。每个选手在给定的高度有三次尝试机会，每个人可以选择他们想开始的高度。
But if they fail to clear the bar at the first height, they get no points. To start earning relatively high points immediately, Dan and Dave made the same aggressive choice. To begin their vault at 15 feet, nine inches. The higher vault is, it takes a while to get to your return to vault at your starting height. So you warm up and they might give you a few other warm
但如果他们在第一个高度没能越过横杆，他们就得不到任何分数。为了立即开始获得相对较高的分数，丹和戴夫做出了同样激进的选择。从15英尺9英寸开始他们的跳跃。撑杆跳越高，回到你的起跳高度就需要一段时间。所以你热身，他们可能会给你一些其他的热身，
ups, but it's never enough. It's the eighth event. You're feeling your legs a little bit. And the sun was really starting to get hot. While we're sitting around the cameras are in our faces. They're falling, it was wherever we go. And I remember just thinking how distracting that was. Well, by the time the warm-ups ended,
但永远不够。这是第八个项目。你的腿有点感觉了。太阳开始变得非常热。当我们坐在那儿时，摄像机就在我们脸上。他们跟着我们，无论我们去哪儿。我记得当时觉得那有多让人分心。嗯，当热身结束时，
it was almost two solid hours till I took my first jump. I vaulted first, I remember that. And so I made my first height and had no problem with it other than my foot was still getting more and more sore. Sat down and you know it was battling the heat again and I remember seeing his first attempt at that same height. You know once they call my name I kind of look down the runway kind of assess the wind, look over at the coach, he gives me a thumbs up. All I remember is putting my hands up way too late and so literally I just went straight up and straight down with hardly any bend in the pole. He
距离我第一次跳跃还有整整两个小时。我先跳，我记得。所以我顺利完成了第一个高度，除了我的脚越来越痛之外，没什么问题。坐下来，你知道，又在对抗高温，我记得看到他在同一个高度的第一次尝试。你知道，一旦他们叫到我的名字，我就看着跑道，评估一下风向，看看教练，他给我竖了个大拇指。我只记得我举起手太晚了，所以实际上我只是直上直下，撑杆几乎没有弯曲。他
looked like he'd never vaulted before. He's just something was way wrong than I'd ever seen him have. And so on my next attempt I make all the adjustments. Come down the runway, good takeoff, good plant, I feel like I'm way over the bar and I come down on it slightly and the bar falls off. And then I start to think it's like, oh no, I'm on a third attempt. You don't want to be on a third attempt. At an opening bar. At an Olympic trials. This height, that's it, or he has lost maybe all chance. He had been on a world record pace and now risking not even qualifying for the team.
看起来好像从来没跳过一样。他只是有些地方出了大问题，比我见过的任何时候都严重。所以在下一次尝试时，我做了所有调整。跑下跑道，起跳不错，撑杆不错，我觉得我完全越过了横杆，但我稍微碰了一下，横杆掉了。然后我开始想，哦不，我在进行第三次尝试。你不想在开场高度进行第三次尝试。在奥运选拔赛上。这个高度，就是这样，否则他可能失去了所有机会。他一直处于世界纪录的节奏，现在却面临甚至无法入选国家队的风险。
That's when I sat up and I was going, well, what is going on here? And it was kind of a quiet in the stands. It wasn't as much Dandy, dandy, dandy You kind of see the crowd begin to stir a little bit. Other athletes sit up and they look over your direction. Ooh, Brian's got two misses. This is opening bars. That is opener. Oh, did he make one?
就在那时，我坐起来，心想，这到底是怎么回事？看台上有一种安静。不再是那么多的“丹，丹，丹”。你可以看到人群开始有点骚动。其他运动员坐起来，看向你的方向。哦，布莱恩有两次失败了。这是开场高度。那是开场。哦，他成功了一次吗？
No, I thought I saw him make one. Then you hear the people talking in the crowd as well. It's like, no, no, he made one. I saw him make one about an hour ago. No, that was a warm up. This third attempt, he might have taken a little run and then stopped and went back. This is his third and final attempt and he goes down the runway and stops. That was not a good start. As soon as I start my run on the third attempt, I get a big gust of wind coming from the right.
不，我以为我看到他成功了一次。然后你听到人群中人们的谈话。就像是，不，不，他成功了一次。我一小时前看到他成功了一次。不，那是热身。这是他的第三次也是最后一次尝试，他跑下跑道然后停了下来。那不是个好的开始。当我开始第三次尝试时，我感觉到一阵来自右侧的大风。
And so I stop. He just didn't look confident. This is it. He's not on the team if he doesn't make this high and he knows it and it's going through his mind. I just tell myself, settle down. Just relax. Just relax. And so I get back there and I take off. And down the runway, I go. There's a look on his face like,
所以我停了下来。他看起来一点也不自信。就是这样。如果他没能越过这个高度，他就进不了队，他知道这一点，这在他的脑海里盘旋。我只是告诉自己，冷静下来。放松。放松。所以我回到后面，起跳。跑下跑道。他脸上有一种表情，就像是，
I'm just gonna go and I'm just, I'll make sure I make it. And I feel pretty good. I plant the pole, the next thing you know, I'm stalled out on the top and I'm looking at the bar and I think,
我只是要跑，我只是，我会确保我能成功。我感觉相当不错。我撑杆，接下来你知道的，我在顶部停滞了，我看着横杆，我想，
get over it somehow. And I can't. It's not even close. Now he went under the pit. I come crashing down to the pit and I'm just in a days. What happened? What what what what happened?
无论如何都要越过去。但我做不到。甚至都不接近。现在他掉进了垫子里。我重重地摔在垫子上，我只是处于恍惚中。发生了什么？发生了什么？
And at that moment, you just I wanted to turn to somebody and say, help me. It was almost if the sun, all that heat that it became cloudy, and it became dark. Because you knew something bad had happened. something bad had happened. I blew a chance to go to the Olympic Games. I'm not on this Olympic team. It was, it was devastating.
在那一刻，我只想转向某人说，帮帮我。几乎就像太阳，所有的热量变得多云，变得黑暗。因为你知道发生了坏事。发生了坏事。我失去了参加奥运会的机会。我没进这个奥运代表队。这真是太令人崩溃了。
I was devastated. I just tried to get away from people. But there's guys with cameras, there's people, and so I cried that I didn't make the team. I cried that I let everybody down. I was kind of in a day, it's just, you know, kind of freaked out by all of it. The thought never, ever crossed my mind that day and nor day were not make that Olympic team. And that just wasn't a thought.
我崩溃了。我只是想远离人群。但到处都是拿着摄像机的人，到处都是人，所以我哭了，因为我没进队。我哭了，因为我让所有人失望了。我当时有点恍惚，你知道，被这一切吓坏了。丹和戴夫没能进入奥运代表队这个想法从来没有在我脑海中出现过。那根本不是一个想法。
My main goal is to win an Olympic gold medal here. And that was what my coaches and I thought my main goal is to win an Olympic gold medal here and that was what my coaches and I thought all along and we were so not ready for it. We were not ready to fail, to not make this team, to not win this meet. It was hard, everybody was still in disbelief, you could hear the buzz in the stands. Oh my gosh, you can't believe it. You are the best athlete in the world. And I knew it was hard to deal with dealing with all the commercials and all the hype and everything that went into it.
我的主要目标是在这里赢得奥运金牌。这就是我和我的教练一直以来的想法，我们根本没准备好面对失败，没进这个队，没赢得这场比赛。这很难，每个人仍然处于难以置信中，你可以听到看台上的嗡嗡声。天哪，你不敢相信。你是世界上最伟大的运动员。我知道处理所有的广告和所有的炒作以及投入其中的一切是多么困难。
It was too much. It was a lot to have to deal with all at once. And the first thing I thought about is you have to get to him and tell him it's going to be OK. Because I cared about him as a person. You know, we were Dan and Dave singular. And everywhere we went, we had to be that person. It was one of those things where,
这太多了。要同时处理所有这些事情真的很难。我首先想到的是，你必须找到他，告诉他一切都会好起来的。因为我关心他这个人。你知道，我们是“丹和戴夫”，单数。无论我们去哪儿，我们都必须是那个人。这是那种情况之一，
dang, the perfect situation wasn't happening. The exact thing that would have been what everybody wanted to see wasn't going to happen. Suddenly, I was alone. Dave Johnson, now all alone, no more Dan and Dave, Dave Johnson. You know, I was able to become Dave again, the real Dave, not the Dave Reebok. Johnson in the Javling competition. No seas thrown a beauty right here. It turns out to be an American record of 244 feet.
该死，完美的情况没有发生。每个人都想看到的完全一样的事情不会发生了。突然间，我独自一人。戴夫·约翰逊，现在孤身一人，不再有丹和戴夫，戴夫·约翰逊。你知道，我能够再次成为戴夫，真正的戴夫，而不是锐步的戴夫。约翰逊在标枪比赛中。看看这投掷，真是太美了。结果是244英尺的美国纪录。
Dave places first in the overall competition. Meanwhile, Dan fails to qualify and they share an emotional embrace when it was over. Dave came over and said, I love you, man.. I love you man. You're gonna be all right I just decided he needed a hug Give him a big hug and just said I'm so sorry that that happened and I just I Couldn't even hug him back, you know, it was just kind of hands on my side. It's just like what the heck just happened kind of hands on my side. It's just like, what the heck just happened? For the next 48 hours, I walked around in a days and I didn't think much about Dan and Dave. Some people asked me, well, what's Reebok going to do? And at the time, I thought,
戴夫在总成绩中排名第一。与此同时，丹未能获得资格，当比赛结束时，他们分享了一个感人的拥抱。戴夫走过来说，我爱你，伙计。我爱你，伙计。你会没事的。我只是决定他需要一个拥抱。给了他一个大大的拥抱，只是说我很抱歉发生了那种事，我甚至无法回抱他，你知道，只是手放在身侧。就像是，到底发生了什么？就像是，到底发生了什么？接下来的48小时，我处于恍惚中，没怎么想丹和戴夫的事。有些人问我，嗯，锐步打算怎么办？当时我想，
I don't care. But I got the real sense that, you know, somebody's just getting yelled at somewhere. There was probably some yelling going on at the ad agency. Rick Siddig was watching the events that afternoon on television from New York. So, it's a bad situation. The mood at the agency is just not crap. Reebok has made a huge investment in these athletes to pump up their credibility in the athletic world and they've got media to fill. And the future of the company is kind of resting on the outcome of this and it's now just gone to hell.
我不在乎。但我有一种真实的感觉，你知道，某人在某个地方正被大声斥责。广告代理公司可能正在进行一些大声的斥责。里克·西迪格那天下午在纽约的电视上观看了比赛。所以，这是一个糟糕的情况。代理公司的气氛简直糟透了。锐步在这些运动员身上投入了巨资，以提升他们在体育界的信誉，他们还有媒体要填补。公司的未来某种程度上取决于这个结果，而现在一切都搞砸了。
And in my head I'm going, oh no, we were planning to be on Johnny Carson, we were planning to be posting Saturday night live. All those commercials they'd already made. They'd made 10 or 15 commercials that we're going to play during the Olympic Games with Dan and Dave there. Steve Miller from Nike was in New Orleans with a few of his colleagues in a small section of seats in the middle of the stands watching the drama play out. Sitting in the stands and watching it was, you know, it was like a dream come true. For months, Steve and Nike had been secretly fantasizing this exact scenario. Yeah, we were actively hoping it's something bad would happen. I don't know, I don't know how else to put it. I'd like to lie and say no, it didn't make a difference.
在我的脑海里，我心想，哦不，我们计划上约翰尼·卡森（Johnny Carson）的节目，我们计划主持《周六夜现场》（Saturday Night Live）。所有那些他们已经制作好的广告。他们制作了10到15则广告，原本打算在奥运会期间播放，丹和戴夫会在那里。耐克的史蒂夫·米勒和他的几位同事在新奥尔良，坐在看台中间的一小块区域，看着戏剧上演。坐在看台上看着它，你知道，这就像梦想成真。几个月来，史蒂夫和耐克一直在秘密幻想这个确切的场景。是的，我们积极地希望发生一些糟糕的事情。我不知道，我不知道该怎么说。我想撒谎说不，那没什么区别。
What it made a difference, of course. The truth is, we were just f***ing happy. What are you gonna say? It was one of those moments where you feel so good, you get a little light headed. It's the first moment in time that I can never remember taking pleasure in somebody else's babe. Reebok, the creator of those Dan and Dave commercials, says that it's huge ad campaign isn't dead
当然有区别。事实是，我们只是他妈的很高兴。你要说什么？这是那种让你感觉如此美妙，以至于有点头晕的时刻之一。这是我记忆中第一次从别人的不幸中获得快乐。锐步，那些丹和戴夫广告的创作者，说它巨大的广告活动还没有死
yet. It just needs a slight re-adjustment. The re-adjustment came in the form of a new series of ads, embracing the change in the Dan and Dave's story. Reebok rebooted its campaign on the fly. They had new ads out within 48 hours. In the coming weeks, there was an ad with Dan Coaching Dave. Now that I've got some free time, I'm helping Dave train.
。它只需要一点点调整。调整以一系列新广告的形式出现，拥抱了丹和戴夫故事中的变化。锐步在飞行中重启了他们的活动。他们在48小时内推出了新广告。在接下来的几周里，有一则丹指导戴夫的广告。既然我有空闲时间，我正在帮助戴夫训练。
Fast to Dave, push it. One with Dave consoling Dan. Hey, you should be happy. You're going to represent your country. You're going for the gold. Yeah, I guess I just wish you were going down and that same ad also announced a new role for Dan O'Brien in Barcelona Dave, I am going huh? I'll be up on the broadcast booth. You mean the goal being being bar-shelona? Uh-huh. Together. Again? Uh-huh. Really? You wanna hug?
对戴夫说，推它。还有一则戴夫安慰丹的广告。嘿，你应该高兴。你要代表你的国家。你要去争夺金牌。是的，我猜我只是希望你也去。丹，那则广告也宣布了丹·奥布莱恩在巴塞罗那的新角色。戴夫，我要去吗？我会坐在广播间里。你是说目标是巴塞罗那？嗯哼。在一起。又在一起？嗯哼。真的吗？你想抱一下吗？
Nah, we already did that. OK. OK. OK. OK, the de-Cathlon resumed this morning at Olympic Stadium, American Dave Johnson expected to contend for the gold medal. When you're in the broadcast booth, it's really hard not to put yourself out there on the
不，我们已经做过了。好的。好的。好的。好的，十项全能今天早上在奥林匹克体育场恢复进行，美国选手戴夫·约翰逊有望争夺金牌。当你坐在广播间里时，真的很难不把自己放在
track. You're at Dwight Stones and the guy who might have been Johnson's toughest competition at the Olympics, Dan O'Brien. It was a little strange, though, looking down there at guys who I thought I could beat for the Olympic gold medal. Yeah, it's just really too bad. You always hate for it to come down to your third attempt and maybe there were moments
赛道上。你是德怀特·斯通斯（Dwight Stones），而那个可能是约翰逊在奥运会上最强劲的对手的人，丹·奥布莱恩。不过，看着那些我认为我可以击败他们赢得奥运金牌的人，感觉有点奇怪。是的，这真的很遗憾。你总是讨厌它归结为你的第三次尝试，也许有那么一刻
when I wasn't horribly complimentary today. Well, Dwight, it looks to me like Dave is just lacked enthusiasm all day long. And I just saw him struggling. And I kept thinking this isn't the Dave Johnson that I saw all spring. This isn't the Dave Johnson that I saw at the Olympic trials. And I thought, you know, Gully, is he crumbling under the pressure? Dave was underperforming, but not because of the pressure. His foot injury from the trials had only gotten worse.
我今天并不是特别赞美。嗯，德怀特，在我看来，戴夫整天都缺乏热情。我看到他在挣扎。我一直想，这不是我在整个春天看到的戴夫·约翰逊。这不是我在奥运选拔赛上看到的戴夫·约翰逊。我想，你知道，天哪，他是在压力下崩溃了吗？戴夫表现不佳，但不是因为压力。他在选拔赛中的脚伤只会变得更糟。
The public didn't know about it, but a few weeks before the games, Dave had met with a doctor about his foot. And the doctor said, you shouldn't go to the Olympics because it's going to break in half. And I'm waiting. I'm the Dave guy from the Reebok commercials. Dan didn't make the team. Didn't you see somebody's got to go?
公众不知道这一点，但在奥运会前几周，戴夫曾就他的脚咨询过医生。医生说，你不应该去参加奥运会，因为它会断成两半。而我正在等待。我是锐步广告里的那个戴夫。丹没进队。你没看到吗？总得有人去吧？
In Barcelona, on a broken foot, starting day two in ninth place, Dave toughed it out and finished third. Dave Johnson becomes the first U.S. medalist in the event since Bruce Jenner back in 1976. You know, he did his absolute best, which was phenomenal to walk away with the bronze medal. Even as I stepped up and received the bronze metal, you know, and saw the American flag go up, I was thinking, man, I'd overcome, you know, this, this Dan and Dave had campaign and the, the broken foot and, and just the career of 14, 15 years of training. And I was
在巴塞罗那，戴夫带着骨折的脚，在第二天以第九名的成绩起步，他咬牙坚持，最终获得了第三名。戴夫·约翰逊成为自1976年布鲁斯·詹纳以来，美国在该项目上的首位奖牌获得者。你知道，他尽了自己最大的努力，能拿到铜牌真是太了不起了。当我走上领奖台接过铜牌，看到美国国旗升起时，我在想，伙计，我克服了这一切，你知道，那个“丹与戴夫”的宣传活动，还有骨折的脚，以及14、15年的训练生涯。我当时
so fortunate to be able to step down from that metal's ceremony and go to the people that really knew me, my family, my coach, and go to the people that really knew me, my family, my coach, and the people that really were there in my life to get me to that moment. Dave wins the bronze medal. Robert's Mellick comes home with the gold from the Czech Republic. Neither Dave nor I claim the title of the world's greatest athlete in Barcelona.
非常幸运，能够走下领奖台，去见那些真正了解我的人——我的家人、我的教练，去见那些真正了解我的人——我的家人、我的教练，以及那些在我生命中真正支持我走到那一刻的人。戴夫赢得了铜牌。罗伯特·梅利克带着来自捷克的金牌回家了。在巴塞罗那，我和戴夫都没有获得“世界最伟大运动员”的称号。
And I think it was two or three days later in USA Today, Reebok has a big ad that says, congratulations to Dave Johnson for winning the Olympic bronze medal. Thank you, Dan and Dave, for a great year. And I think for me at that particular moment, Dan and Dave ended. Dan and Dave was over as an ad campaign and with Dave coming off a major injury, Dan and Dave looked to be over as a major rivalry too. But Dan O'Brien was already thinking about what was next. All I could do was really think about what was down the road for me. And the great thing about track and field is you don't have to wait every four years for a big event. I knew I was going to get another shot the following year at a world championship.
我想大概两三天后，《今日美国》上刊登了锐步的一则大广告，上面写着：祝贺戴夫·约翰逊获得奥运会铜牌。感谢丹和戴夫，度过了伟大的一年。我想对我来说，在那一刻，“丹与戴夫”结束了。作为广告活动的“丹与戴夫”结束了，而随着戴夫遭遇重伤，“丹与戴夫”作为一场重大竞争似乎也结束了。但丹·奥布莱恩已经在思考下一步了。我所能做的就是思考我未来的路。田径运动最棒的地方在于，你不需要每四年才等来一次大型赛事。我知道第二年的世界锦标赛我还有机会。
Starting in the fall of 1992, just a few weeks after the Barcelona games and for the next few years, then O'Brien went on the best tear of his life. September that same year, I break the world record. The winter of 1993, I win the first Heptathlon World Endor Championships, I break the world record. I win a U.S. outdoor title in Eugene, Oregon. I remember eating lunch with Bruce Jenner and Bruce kept telling me, only thing people are going to remember is the Olympic Games. And I thought to myself, man, this guy's crazy. He doesn't know what he's talking about. He didn't have a lot of money.
从1992年秋天开始，也就是巴塞罗那奥运会结束几周后，接下来的几年里，丹·奥布莱恩开启了他人生中最辉煌的时期。同年9月，我打破了世界纪录。1993年冬天，我赢得了首届室内七项全能世锦赛冠军，并打破了世界纪录。我在俄勒冈州尤金市赢得了美国室外赛冠军。我记得和布鲁斯·詹纳一起吃午饭，布鲁斯一直对我说，人们唯一会记住的就是奥运会。我心想，伙计，这家伙疯了。他根本不知道自己在说什么。他当时没多少钱。
He's just a little bit of a guy who's been in the field for a long time. He's just a little bit of a guy who's been in the field for a long time. He's just a little bit of a guy who's been in the field for a long time. He's just a little bit of a guy who's been in the field for a long time. Bruce kept telling me, only thing people are going to remember is the Olympic games. And I thought to myself, man, this guy's crazy. He doesn't know what he's talking about. He didn't have world championships when he was a competing athlete. I get to compete at world championships every two years.
他只是个在赛场上待了很久的小人物。他只是个在赛场上待了很久的小人物。他只是个在赛场上待了很久的小人物。他只是个在赛场上待了很久的小人物。布鲁斯一直对我说，人们唯一会记住的就是奥运会。我心想，伙计，这家伙疯了。他根本不知道自己在说什么。他当运动员时还没有世锦赛。而我每两年就能参加一次世锦赛。
But it wasn't until later that I realized, man, Bruce was right. So Daniel Bryan set his sights on the next Olympics. And the chance to win a medal people would care about. But even as he was winning meat after meat, Dan felt he needed help, because he was still struggling with the mental side of the de-Cathlon. I used to get so nervous before I competed
但直到后来我才意识到，伙计，布鲁斯是对的。于是丹·奥布莱恩将目光投向了下一届奥运会。他渴望赢得一枚人们会在意的奖牌。但即使在不断赢得比赛的过程中，丹也感到他需要帮助，因为他仍在与十项全能的心理障碍作斗争。我以前在比赛前总是非常紧张，
that I would question why I do this, almost throwing up, wanting to quit. My name is Dr. Jim Reardon. I'm a sports psychologist from Columbus, Ohio. Dan had come to Dr. Reardon to talk about that anxiety he faced before every competition. But Dr. Reardon suspected there was a deeper element at play. The fallout from the Mist pole vault in New Orleans. the fallout from the Mistpovalt in New Orleans.
以至于我会质疑自己为什么要这样做，几乎要呕吐，想要放弃。我是吉姆·里尔登医生。我是一名来自俄亥俄州哥伦布市的运动心理学家。丹来找里尔登医生，谈论他每次比赛前所面临的焦虑。但里尔登医生怀疑背后有更深层的原因。新奥尔良撑杆跳失误带来的后果。新奥尔良撑杆跳失误带来的后果。
What can happen is people come in for treatment from trauma and the first thing the therapist wants to talk about is the trauma. And the last thing the person wants to talk about is the trauma. I just made the decision pretty early on. If he brings it up and wants to talk about it, we'll talk about it. But if he doesn't, then we won't, because he'll know when the time will be right. And so we didn't. For almost three years, the polvaltness didn't come up.
可能会发生的情况是，人们因为创伤来寻求治疗，治疗师首先想谈论的就是创伤。而当事人最不想谈论的也是创伤。我早早就做出了决定。如果他提起并想谈论它，我们就谈。但如果他不提，那我们就不谈，因为他会知道什么时候才是合适的时机。所以我们没谈。近三年来，撑杆跳的事从未被提起。
They talked about other parts of the de-Cathlon, their personal lives, the real world, but never New Orleans. Until one day in August 1995, 311 days until the next Olympic trials. We were having this conversation and he kind of started it out by saying, gosh, you know what? Last night was weird. I had a dream about the pole vault from 1992. He said, I haven't thought about that in years. And I'm thinking to myself, okay, I guess this is the moment. Over the coming months, Reardon decided that he had to take a big, aggressive step.
他们谈论了十项全能的其他部分、他们的个人生活、现实世界，但从未谈论过新奥尔良。直到1995年8月的一天，距离下一次奥运选拔赛还有311天。我们当时正在交谈，他开头说，天哪，你知道吗？昨晚真奇怪。我做了一个关于1992年撑杆跳的梦。他说，我已经好几年没想过那件事了。我心想，好吧，我想这就是那个时刻了。在接下来的几个月里，里尔登决定他必须采取一个重大且积极的步骤。
Dan had to watch footage of his failure in New Orleans. Somebody got me a copy of it. And I had a couple of back in those days DVDs made. I kind of caught him off guard. And I said, I got something I want you to look at. And we watched it. He's watching it and I'm watching him. It was ghastly.
丹必须观看他在新奥尔良失败的录像。有人给了我一份拷贝。在那个年代，我让人做了几张DVD。我有点让他措手不及。我说，我有样东西想让你看看。然后我们看了。他在看录像，我在观察他。那场面太可怕了。
It brought back all the feelings that I had in 1992. I remembered seeing the white t-shirts, dandered-dave t-shirts in the crowd. I remember what side of the field I was on and how hot it was. Oh my gosh, it was hot. And I remember thinking to myself, holy mackerel. I relived a horror of missing on a third attempt. And coming down, landing on the pit, and just being in a complete days, and it was absolutely ghastly to go through those emotions again. The video continued to roll, it showed Dave come over to hug me. I couldn't, I didn't even know what to say afterwards. And I said, what do you think?
它带回了我在1992年的所有感受。我记得看到人群中那些白色的T恤，那些“丹与戴夫”的T恤。我记得我当时在赛场的哪一边，天气有多热。天哪，太热了。我记得我当时心想，天哪。我重温了第三次试跳失败的恐怖。落地，摔在垫子上，整个人完全处于恍惚状态，再次经历那些情绪真是太可怕了。视频继续播放，显示戴夫走过来拥抱我。事后我甚至不知道该说什么。我说，你觉得怎么样？
And he said, I don't want to look at this. And I said, okay. And then I replayed it. And I said, what do you think? And he said, I feel like, I feel like throwing up. And I said, I said, you know what? I would much rather have you feel like that in a hotel room in Chula Vista in December than on the runway in Atlanta in June.
他说，我不想看这个。我说，好吧。然后我重播了一遍。我说，你觉得怎么样？他说，我觉得，我觉得想吐。我说，你知道吗？我宁愿你在12月丘拉维斯塔的酒店房间里有这种感觉，也不愿你在6月亚特兰大的跑道上有这种感觉。
I wanted him to get to the point where he would have seen that video so many times that he would just get pissed off when he would think about it. And develop the mindset that pressure is nothing. Pressure is going to bring out the best in me. It's a trials double header today folks. Hello, I'm Bob Kausters. We have competition from Brackenfield here at the Olympic Stadium in Atlanta. And from Indiana. The trials for the 1996 Olympics were held in Atlanta, which would be the site of the games themselves later that summer. And once again, the Decaflon competition featured two familiar faces, Daniel Bryan and Dave Johnson.
我希望他能达到这样一个境界：看过那段视频无数次后，当他再想起它时，只会感到愤怒。并培养出一种心态：压力算什么。压力只会激发我最好的状态。各位，今天是选拔赛的双重赛。大家好，我是鲍勃·考斯特。我们正在亚特兰大奥林匹克体育场进行田径比赛。还有来自印第安纳州的比赛。1996年奥运会选拔赛在亚特兰大举行，那里也是当年夏天晚些时候奥运会的举办地。十项全能比赛再次出现了两张熟悉的面孔：丹·奥布莱恩和戴夫·约翰逊。
But no one was talking about Dan and Dave in 1996. No Reebok campaign, in fact, Dan was a Nike athlete by this point. And Dave was living the typical battle of the injured athlete, one problem piling up on top of another. These trials were not about who would be the world's greatest athlete, Dan or Dave, the storyline was all Dan O'Brien. Well, Tom, I would say that the 1992 Olympic trials debacle by Dan O'Brien is a part of track and field lore and legend at this point. I was nervous going into the 96 trials. I'll be honest with you.
但在1996年，没人再谈论“丹与戴夫”了。没有锐步的宣传活动，事实上，丹当时已经是耐克旗下的运动员了。而戴夫正经历着受伤运动员典型的挣扎，一个问题接着一个问题。这些选拔赛不再是关于谁是世界最伟大运动员——丹还是戴夫，故事的主角只有丹·奥布莱恩。嗯，汤姆，我会说丹·奥布莱恩在1992年奥运选拔赛上的惨败，现在已经成为田径界的传说和轶事了。参加96年选拔赛时我很紧张。老实说。
I can remember waking up the morning that the decafalon started. I put my head in my wife's lap and just sobbed because I was nervous and I was scared, you know, but I needed to get that out. I think every decafied who competes now is affected by his no height in the pole vault four years ago. I would submit that this will be the hardest track meet that Donald Bryan will ever compete in. Even if Dan had felt like he'd put 1992 behind him, the organizers in Atlanta wouldn't let him shake it so easily.
我记得十项全能开始的那天早上醒来。我把头埋在妻子的怀里痛哭，因为我很紧张，我很害怕，你知道，但我需要把这些情绪发泄出来。我认为现在参加比赛的每一位十项全能选手都受到了他四年前撑杆跳没成绩的影响。我认为这将是丹·奥布莱恩参加过的最艰难的田径比赛。即使丹觉得他已经把1992年抛在脑后，亚特兰大的组织者也不会让他轻易摆脱。
I'll never forget, as I walked out to run the hundred meters, the start of the very first day at the Atlanta Olympic Trials, I look up at the big screen on the north end of the side of the field and they're showing my failure in the pool vault. When I saw that footage, I was pissed off. I don't even know to this day whose idea it was. It really didn't upset me that I saw the video. I kind of almost chuckled.
我永远不会忘记，当我走出去准备跑100米时，那是亚特兰大奥运选拔赛第一天的开始，我抬头看向赛场北端的大屏幕，他们正在播放我撑杆跳失败的画面。当我看到那段录像时，我很生气。直到今天我也不知道那是谁的主意。看到视频并没有真正让我难过。我甚至差点笑出声来。
I laughed it off. Because of the training that Dan had done, it became just nothing. I was ready. Proving he was ready, Dan got off to a great start. Going in today, too, he was in second place. And he'd remained there through the hurdles and the discus.
我一笑置之。因为丹所做的训练，那已经变得没什么大不了的了。我准备好了。为了证明他准备好了，丹有了一个很好的开始。进入第二天时，他排在第二名。在跨栏和铁饼比赛后，他依然保持着这个位置。
And with seven of the ten events complete, next, the dreaded pole vault. What must be going through his mind? I get a little nervous, and you know, just I'm tired of sitting around, 20 minutes has gone by, maybe a half hour since I took my last warm-up jump. Dan was cooling off, and just like in 1992, he was losing his rhythm. So he made a last-minute decision to change his strategy. Two bars before I'm supposed to come in, I get a little antsy, and I walked over to my coach Rick Sloan and I said, what do you think about me coming in at the next bar? It was a scheduled bar lower than I was supposed to come in
在十个项目完成了七个之后，接下来是令人恐惧的撑杆跳。他心里在想什么？我有点紧张，你知道，我只是厌倦了等待，距离我上一次热身跳已经过去了20分钟，也许半小时了。丹正在冷却下来，就像1992年一样，他正在失去节奏。所以他做了一个临时的决定来改变策略。在预定起跳高度的前两档，我感到有点不安，我走到我的教练里克·斯隆身边说，你觉得我下一档起跳怎么样？那比我原计划的起跳高度低了一档。
and he's just like, you feel good? Go for it. Do it. I didn't tell anybody else. I looked at my coach and all of a sudden I took my sweats off and I step up to the runway and they say, oh, Brian up. And I think that surprised even my competitors at the time. Well, Tom, they made one Intelligent Decision. They're starting at a height one foot below what Dan started it four years ago.
他只是说，你感觉好吗？那就去吧。去做吧。我没告诉其他人。我看着我的教练，突然脱掉运动服，走上跑道，他们喊道：奥布莱恩准备。我想这甚至让当时的竞争对手都感到惊讶。嗯，汤姆，他们做了一个明智的决定。他们起跳的高度比丹四年前起跳的高度低了一英尺。
And everyone in the stadium holding their collective breath. I'm on the runway. I got my starter pole. Don't even think about missing. Just think, you know what, I'm here to vault. Head down the runway and think to myself, look, I'm probably not as warmed up as I should be. I push a little harder than I normally would
体育场里的每个人都屏住了呼吸。我在跑道上。我拿着我的起跳杆。根本不要去想失败。只想，你知道吗，我是来跳高的。冲向跑道，心想，看，我可能没有达到应有的热身程度。我比平时更用力地推了一下
on a first attempt jump. As I take off the ground, my top hand slips about an inch and I re-grip real quick. Swing up, go over the bar, and I got a first attempt made. That's kind of like hitting the lottery. And by virtue of that first attempt make, I'm on the team. Here is the sweet irony for O'Brien. It looks like Dan O'Brien is going to gain the lead
在第一次试跳时。当我起跳时，我的上手滑了大约一英寸，我迅速重新抓握。摆动，越过横杆，我第一次试跳成功了。这就像中了彩票一样。凭借那次成功的试跳，我进入了国家队。这对奥布莱恩来说真是绝妙的讽刺。看起来丹·奥布莱恩要领先了
into the Catalan because of his performance here in the pole vault. The event that was his undoing four years ago. Now also a few hours later, Dan would finish first in the trials de-Cathlon, a start contrast to four years earlier. In 1992, it had been Dave Johnson watching Dan struggle. This time, the roles were reversed. I ended up placing sixth and pretty much knew it that was my retirement after that event after that Olympic trials and you know I just remember just being able to encourage Dan
进入十项全能，因为他在撑杆跳中的表现。这正是四年前导致他失败的项目。几个小时后，丹在选拔赛的十项全能中获得了第一名，与四年前形成了鲜明对比。1992年，是戴夫·约翰逊看着丹挣扎。这一次，角色互换了。我最终获得了第六名，在那次比赛、那次奥运选拔赛之后，我基本上知道那是我的退役之战了，你知道，我只记得能够鼓励丹
to go on in Atlanta and represent the United States. Dan here comes Dan O'Brien. Let's let the crowd carry him home here is finally going to make a US Olympic team. Daniel Bryan was World Champion, record holder. He'd exercised the demons of New Orleans. Now the only job left to do was to win the gold six weeks later. The trouble is when you've won everything, except for the Olympic gold medal,
在亚特兰大继续前进，代表美国。丹，丹·奥布莱恩来了。让观众欢呼着送他回家，他终于要进入美国奥运代表队了。丹·奥布莱恩是世界冠军，纪录保持者。他已经驱散了新奥尔良的恶魔。现在唯一剩下的工作就是六周后赢得金牌。问题是，当你赢得了除奥运金牌以外的一切时，
and you feel like it's the last thing on your list, it's not as exciting as it could be. It was stressful. I was trying to just not make mistakes. Atlanta's Olympic Stadium were that a Catalan competition continued today, and for a report on day two in the Catalan, let's go to Dwightstones.
当你觉得这是你清单上的最后一项时，它并没有想象中那么令人兴奋。这很有压力。我只是尽量不犯错。亚特兰大奥林匹克体育场，十项全能比赛今天继续进行，关于十项全能第二天的报道，让我们连线德怀特·斯通斯。
In Atlanta, in his quest to finally settle that question, who is the world's greatest athlete that had first been asked four years earlier? Daniel Bryan's first day of competition went off without a hitch. As prepared as I was for the Olympic Games, sometimes what you're not prepared for is what other people are going to do. This crazy young guy from Germany, Frank Busman, just young kid, he had personal best after personal best.
在亚特兰大，为了最终解决那个四年前首次提出的问题——谁是世界最伟大的运动员？丹·奥布莱恩的第一天比赛进行得非常顺利。尽管我为奥运会做了充分准备，但有时你无法准备的是别人会做什么。这个来自德国的疯狂年轻人，弗兰克·布斯曼，只是个小伙子，他不断刷新个人最好成绩。
He was going crazy. So on this new stage Dan suddenly had a new rival. Boozman, the German, was right on his heels. Through day one, through the pole vault, and right up to the de-Cathlon's final two events, the Javelin and the 1500 meters, a race that had never been Dan's strongest. I need a big lead before the 1500 meters. And when I got to the Javlan, I didn't have as big a lead as I would have liked. He was a little too close for comfort.
他简直疯了。所以在这个新舞台上，丹突然有了一个新对手。德国人布斯曼紧追不舍。经过第一天，经过撑杆跳，一直到十项全能的最后两个项目——标枪和1500米，这从来都不是丹的强项。在1500米之前我需要很大的领先优势。当我进行标枪比赛时，我的领先优势并没有我希望的那么大。他离我太近了，让人不安。
Let's head back to the track, the two-day to Cathlon concluding tonight with a report on how the car was going. And so as I got into the Javlan, it was the twilight of the night. The Olympic Stadium was packed with hometown American fans rooting on Dan and a noisy contingent of Germans rooting on Boosman. Each of the competitors selected a javelin and took their first throw. Dan's first attempt was disappointing, but he tried to stay calm, scanning the crowd as he waited his next turn. I look over and see a guy in a red, white and blue Jersey,
让我们回到赛道，两天的十项全能今晚结束，报道一下比赛进展。所以当我进入标枪比赛时，已经是黄昏了。奥林匹克体育场挤满了为丹加油的美国本土粉丝，还有一群为布斯曼加油的吵闹的德国人。每位选手选了一支标枪并进行了第一次投掷。丹的第一次尝试令人失望，但他试图保持冷静，在等待下一次轮次时扫视着人群。我抬头看，看到一个穿着红白蓝球衣的家伙，
USA Jersey, and a Steve Johnson. He's got his oakles on the back of his head, backwards like he always used to wear them, but he was down on the front row, you know, just kind of hanging. Dave had been standing with the U.S. coaches, quietly watching the drama play out. But now, he was noticing something. As Dan threw his first throw, I think I could tell that the javelin he was throwing wasn't flying exactly as well as it should be for his type of throwing. After the second throw, another disappointment,
美国队球衣，是史蒂夫·约翰逊。他戴着奥克利眼镜，像往常一样反戴在脑后，但他就在前排，你知道，只是在那儿待着。戴夫一直和美国教练站在一起，静静地看着事态发展。但现在，他注意到了什么。当丹进行第一次投掷时，我想我能看出他投的那支标枪飞得并不像他那种投掷方式应有的那样好。第二次投掷后，又是一次失望，
Dan came over to consult with his coaches on the sidelines, with Dave standing right nearby. We had that eye contact. And I say to Dave, which javelin should I use? You got 100 to choose from out there. I had him pick out the javelin that I knew would work really well, you know, because I know the javelin is just my best event. Dave, Dave said the 90 meter Neemith, and I knew exactly which Javlin he was talking about, and I said, all right. Something about him being there, it put me at ease. It was just refreshing to my soul. I just felt good that he was going to be there to witness my greatest moment.
丹走到场边咨询他的教练，戴夫就站在附近。我们有了眼神交流。我对戴夫说，我该用哪支标枪？那里有100支供你选择。我让他挑出那支我知道会用得很好的标枪，你知道，因为我知道标枪是我最好的项目。戴夫说，90米的尼米思，我确切地知道他说的是哪支标枪，我说，好吧。他在这里让我感到安心。这对我来说是一种灵魂的慰藉。我只是觉得很高兴他能在这里见证我最伟大的时刻。
And Dano stepped up to the line for his third throw. He needs a cushion for the 1500. He unleashed a five and a half personal best. And made the 1500. I'm going to have personal best. Maybe in my mind I might have stepped out of myself and went out into his body a little bit. And I got to be damned for about 20 seconds and help him throw that thing. Oh, I did it, Dad! True words were never spoken. Dad, Brian, is on the ring.
丹·奥布莱恩走上起跑线进行第三次投掷。他需要为1500米争取缓冲。他投出了比个人最好成绩远五英尺半的成绩。并完成了1500米。我要有个人最好成绩了。也许在我的脑海里，我可能已经跳出了自己，进入了他的身体一点点。我变成了丹，持续了大约20秒，帮他投出了那一掷。哦，我做到了，丹！这是最真诚的话语。丹·奥布莱恩在赛场上。
I threw farther than Frank Busman so I didn't give up any points. I didn't give up any ground. This is what it's all about. Daddell Bryan is on the ring. Praise God the gold. I'm going to win an Olympic gold medal. Daddell Bryan, sorry to the courage of a world champion. Adam on the big champion, picking it up.
我投得比弗兰克·布斯曼远，所以我没有丢分。我没有丢掉任何优势。这就是比赛的意义所在。丹·奥布莱恩在赛场上。赞美上帝，金牌。我要赢得奥运金牌了。丹·奥布莱恩，展现了世界冠军的勇气。他是大冠军，拿到了金牌。
When Dan won a gold medal in 96, I was just glad that he came full circle for him. Being able to go through, but stick through, and not give up on the sport. And it was great to see him finally being on Olympic champions. And Dan don't buy it, takes title of the world's greatest athlete. I think it would be tough to talk about Dana Dave if I hadn't come back in 96 and won the gold. But I think failing in 1992 gave me an opportunity to rewrite the narrative. I had to change people's minds every time I stepped out
当丹在96年赢得金牌时，我只是很高兴他对他来说画上了一个圆满的句号。能够坚持下去，不放弃这项运动。看到他最终成为奥运冠军真是太棒了。丹·奥布莱恩夺得了世界最伟大运动员的称号。我想如果我没有在96年回来并赢得金牌，谈论“丹与戴夫”会很困难。但我认为1992年的失败给了我重写叙事的机会。每次我走上赛道，我都必须改变人们的想法。
out of the track. People when they think of Dan and Dave they remember something went wrong. Reebok, they had this big campaign that we both were going to be at the Olympics and then only one of us went so it was a failure because of that but the reality of that situation is the campaign was a huge success. They sold more shoes of that particular running cross-trainers shoe than any other shoe throughout the year and a half that they were promoting it. That whole year was such a great experience except for two hours on the second day in the eighth event of the de-calfon.
人们想到“丹与戴夫”时，他们记得的是出了差错。锐步，他们有一个盛大的宣传活动，我们俩都要参加奥运会，结果只有一个人去了，所以那是一次失败。但现实情况是，那次活动非常成功。在他们推广的一年半时间里，他们卖出的那种跑步交叉训练鞋比任何其他鞋款都多。那整整一年都是一段很棒的经历，除了十项全能第二天第八个项目的那两个小时。
I meet people who say, I remember where I was when you didn't make that third attempt in the pole vault. They have they have where were they stories when Daniel Bryan didn't make the Olympic team. And I think that's just in our human nature. We are just programmed to remember the bad times a little bit better than the good times. People remember the field goal that was missed. People remember the free throws that the guy didn't make. Nothing prepares you for really having your dream just kind of slip out from underneath you.
我遇到人们说，我记得当你撑杆跳没能完成第三次试跳时我在哪里。他们有关于丹·奥布莱恩没能进入奥运代表队的“当时我在哪里”的故事。我想这就是我们的人性。我们被设定为记住坏时光比记住好时光稍微深刻一点。人们记得错失的射门。人们记得那个人没投进的罚球。没有什么能让你真正准备好面对梦想从你脚下溜走。
But a personality, a great performance, can change an athlete's life. To be settled in Barcelona. The Trials of Dan and Dave was hosted and produced by Jody Evergan with reporting by Andrew Mombo, sound design and original scoring by Ryan Ross Smith. Julia Lowry Henderson, Rose Evelith Taylor Barfield and Kate McCollough are the other producers at 30 for 30 podcasts. You can find the series on Apple podcasts or at 30 for 30podcast.com. The first season is five documentaries, the latest one just came out this week, and
但个性，一场伟大的表现，可以改变一个运动员的生活。《巴塞罗那的审判：丹与戴夫》由乔迪·埃弗根主持并制作，安德鲁·蒙博报道，瑞安·罗斯·史密斯负责声音设计和原创配乐。朱莉娅·洛瑞·亨德森、罗斯·埃夫利斯、泰勒·巴菲尔德和凯特·麦卡洛是30 for 30播客的其他制作人。你可以在苹果播客或30for30podcast.com上找到该系列。第一季有五部纪录片，最新的一部本周刚刚发布，
it's a story about a huge casino caper with the world's most famous poker player and his mysterious accomplice, one millions of dollars using a flaw in the design of certain playing cards. Check it out. 99% of visible is a project of radio topia and KALW in San Francisco and produced on Radio Row. In beautiful, downtown, Oakland, California. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars in the show at 99PI Org, or on Instagram, Tumblr, and
这是一个关于一场巨大的赌场骗局的故事，世界上最著名的扑克玩家和他的神秘同伙，利用某些扑克牌设计上的缺陷赢得了数百万美元。去看看吧。《99%隐形》是旧金山RadioTopia和KALW的一个项目，在Radio Row制作。在美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心。你可以在Facebook上找到该节目并参与讨论。你可以在推特上关注我@RomanMars，关注节目@99PIOrg，或者在Instagram、Tumblr和
Reddit too. But if you've always wondered what those big two-digit codes painted on airport runways meant, you can find the answer on our website at 99pi.org Radio to PI. From PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
Reddit上也可以。但如果你一直想知道机场跑道上那些涂着的大号两位数代码是什么意思，你可以在我们的网站99pi.org Radio to PI上找到答案。来自PRX。本集还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。